[Music]
impossible is nothing doing nothing is
easy so do nothing every day is a fresh
new start to go straight back to bed you
can never fail if you never try you may
not be strong you may not be good enough
you may never even be a decent person oh
you caught me reading my favorite
book that's right bestselling
motivational author here 20 24 is
approaching and it's time to get
motivated how's your Investment
Portfolio going what about your side
hustle you had do have a side hustle
right at least tell me you shave your
balls
God I wanted to make this video to help
you guys get motivated yeah because
every single time I do a Q&A everyone's
like I need motivation help me I need
motivation I don't know why this has
been bestowed on me I don't know how to
say this without sounding like an
but it's just not something I
struggle with I I struggle with a lot of
stuff okay no but motivation just isn't
one of them I realize just how weird
motivational stuff is online I don't
know if you've seen these type of videos
why Sigma males are the extremely
dangerous one of the biggest mistakes
you can make is underestimating a sigma
male are you talking about just because
they God damn it not the typical alpha
male does not mean they are not
dangerous Sigma males are the type of
guy who is quiet but deadly males
are it's like an infestation my mind
these are everywhere I am the greatest
there is no one better than me and I
Know It people watch
these do you want a bite I'm on a diet
but thank you no need to lose any weight
you're kidding right you look great very
th can always be a little thinner you
can always be thinner look better well
maybe we shouldn't go out to dinner
I don't want to ruin your willpower
that's all
right I'm not very good at controlling
It Anyway doesn't he cut her off with a
chainsaw like what's the
motivation Sigma mindset motivation
self-improvement I wanted to share my
thoughts on motivation today to help you
guys get motivated so you can turn that
beta mindset into a sigma grind
set
I'm so sorry chapter one yes this video
has chapters habits there is an
abundance of videos on this topic
already but the Greeks figured the
out 2,000 years ago 2,000 years ago they
were like bro you got to hit the gym
come on stop being lazy what are you
baed Plato himself actually said
adjustable dumbbells are all you really
need for a cost efficient well-rounded
workout actually when I was looking into
stuff for this video I real realize
Aristotle actually said something about
the 4:00 a.m. grind you know how there's
so many videos about 4:00 a.m. workout
or 4:00 a.m. go up and do apparently
Aristotle said Rising before daylight is
also to be commended it is a healthy
habit and gives more time for management
of the household as well as liberal
studies that 4:00 a.m. liberal studies
grind Aristotle Sigma confirm but anyway
the Greeks understood the importance of
habit not necessarily habits to just
exercise or motivate you to do certain
things but your whole character is is
built around habit Aristotle even
claimed that virtue itself came from
heaven so this is not innate in us but
something that we need to practice to
then gradually make it become part a
stable part of your character it might
seem that for some people it's easy to
do certain things but it's because they
develop this over time and so can you
there's actually a misquote by Aristotle
that says we are what we repeatedly do
Excellence then is not an act but a
habit ah so beautiful shame he never
said
it Greek writing unfortunately doesn't
sound like it would fit on a gym t-shirt
but it does sort of Encompass what
Aristotle was saying about habit
although grossly simplified since
there's such an abundance of literature
and videos and whatnot about motivation
and and people always ask me oh I want
to read philosophy where should I start
I would highly recommend epic tit
specifically not this one the inidian
this one just has it contained and the
inidian literally translate to handbook
I didn't know this but it's meant to
keep practicing it's not that you read a
book once and you're Wise It's Something
philosophy is something that you should
always sort of keep working on keep
practicing make it part of your
character through habit I think there's
so much modern take on problems that
aren't any different now from what they
were back then we are literally standing
on the should shoulders of giants why
not take advantage of it so let's read
some passages from it that I picked out
here we have address to someone who has
been caught cheating on their wife no
wait that's not the one to someone who
became a little too excited in the theat
what the ah here we go how to fight
against Impressions every habit and
faculty is formed or strengthened by the
corresponding act walking makes you walk
better running makes you a better Runner
if you want to be literate read if you
want to be a painter paint go a month
without reading occupied with something
else and you'll see what the result is
so if you like doing something do it
regularly if you don't like doing
something make a habit of doing
something different so whenever you do
something even just once good or bad
you've automatically made it easier for
you to do that again that's why it's
always good to examine yourself and
consciously choose which path you want
to take habit shouldn't be so mindless
uh repeating of action but rather a
deliberate attempt of where you want to
take your life
I think it's good to ask yourself why
you want to develop a habit I think for
a lot of people it often comes down to
maybe an end goal or appearances you
want to reach certain things but I think
if you do it for those sort of reasons
you're just making it easier to quit
when it gets hard and easier to quit
once you reach that goal to me life
isn't or shouldn't be an end goal it's
rather fleeting and short the goal of
developing different habits should be
for you to develop yourself your
character and who you want to be and
another beauty of not worrying about the
end goal is to look at it as yes I'm not
may not be exactly where I want to be
but at least I am on the right path and
that doesn't matter if you're starting
or wherever you are it it doesn't matter
so habits can be a great tool but I also
think they can be quite harmful if
you're not careful I think they can
instill a sort of false sense of
controlling people especially if you are
looking at things for an end goal where
if I do these specific things then I'll
reach this goal absolutely for sure I'll
be successful because this person told
me to do it this way life shouldn't just
be a string of repeated motions a lot of
the best moments in life come from
spontaneity so always examine yourself
and what you're doing and you can't go
that wrong right what wrong can come out
of it know yourself that's my little
take on habits I love habits it makes me
feel like I'm living the life I want to
and it makes me feel like if hits the
fan tomorrow I still live the way way I
want to I get a lot of joy out of it
it's helped me being consistent with
things I think are really positive for
me in life
anyway the master has no possessions
except gfuel the more he drinks G fuel
the happier he is the more he buys gfuel
the wealthier he is gfuel nourishes by
not forging by not dominating the master
leads PewDiePie's lingan Berry is the
best flavor wow too thanks for the shout
out all memes aside huge thanks to gfuel
for sponsoring this video and a great
partnership this year but bigger thanks
to you guys because gfuel lingonberry
was one of the best selling
flavors I told you I drink gfuel before
any video so I don't look all dead
inside whenever I have a task that
requires a lot of energy I just know I
have a g- fuel at least to help me power
through and especially as a newborn baby
parent I need the g-u when you need that
extra kick it's clean energy that keeps
you going but the flavors is really what
you stay for so check it out stuck up
with link in the description and thank
you g for sponsoring this
video chapter 2 action what prompts
action why do anything why you click on
video I don't know according to Buddhism
will comes from wanting pleasure you
want pleasure right from
me and by not having it we suffer
most beings live immersed in the
enjoyment of sensual Pleasures others
driven by the need for power status and
esteem pass their lives in vain attempts
to feel an unquenchable thirst I think
this is important to remind yourself you
will never be satisfied you just won't
Napoleon kept trying to
conquer when is it ever enough how much
stuff do you need ask anyone on the
planet almost they'll want something
more I think everyone has this fictional
image in their head like if I had this
then then I'll be Satisfied no you won't
no you won't I guarantee it sorry to
call you on while this idea of wanting
sensual Pleasures receiving them
suffering in between and then receiving
it not feeling satisfied feels like a
sort of pessimistic view of existence
that doesn't seem very fun to me at
least Buddhism does teach you how to
overcome it but I also believe it has
Merit again to examine your actions and
make conscious choices of of what you
want to do are you indulging something
deliberately or just for the pleasure of
it it actually helped me I've said this
many times so it's getting boring but it
really did help me examine my actions
with with drinking I really I wouldn't
even even thought about it otherwise I
was really just drinking for the sake of
feeling good I had anxiety at night and
I wanted to get rid of
it too much information and it helped me
realize and just caught it away from my
life entirely and I'm free from that
suffering because I don't have that
craving craving according to Buddhism is
suffering and to be honest I feel like
I'm still always trying to fight bad
habits as much as I love habits bad
habits are equally easy for me to pick
up Doom scrolling on the phone is such a
typical example especially watching
short videos like Tik toks and and
YouTube shorts because to me it doesn't
feel like a conscious Choice it feels
rather that I'm mindlessly doing it for
for the sake of being entertained at the
moment don't misunderstand me as well
even with Buddhism ples are fine as long
as it's deliberate and not attached but
it doesn't feel very deliberate when I'm
just
like was that on Reddit I hate it I hate
that habit of mine going back to the
Greeks actually for a moment there's
another passage of Epic Titus what Aid
can we find to combat habit the opposed
habit against sophistry one should have
the practice and exercise of rational
argument against specu Impressions one
should have clear preconceptions
polished and ready to hand I don't like
this translation cuz I don't understand
the words I did a video recently where I
started picking up drawing and the
reason I wanted to do that was because
instead of just spending 10 minutes on
social media and if I have that time
which I as a new dad I don't have much
time and and instead of having that 10
minute that I get for free spending on
social media I thought why not just do
something more deliberate that I
actually makes me feel good and that's
why I picked up drawing so to counter a
bad habit do a good habit chapter three
our goal goal what should we strive for
I don't know what's the point of
anything Fu I didn't think of
that I think when people strive for
certain goals there is usually an idea
of success and recognition in mind which
isn't unreasonable by the way but it's
usually pitched in this abundance
especially in those Tik Tok videos that
I showed before like having a giant
mansion or five Yachts I remember I find
it so frustrating when I was starting
off on YouTube Because when media wanted
to interview me I told my entire story
and I thought it was great at least from
my perspective it was crazy right I had
U gone from quitting University working
at a hot dog sand barely making any
money to all of a sudden reaching
millions of people that to me was just
such an unbelievable leap yeah it was
incomprehensible I thought it was insane
but then the article comes out and it's
just like Pewdiepie makes money it's
like for
sake is that all anyone cares about I
get it it's a new it was a New Concept
at that time as well but uh it's always
what's at the Forefront that's the sort
of how we measure success I suppose
which hey money isn't all bad okay I
don't want to be all preachy beachy but
I it's a terrible metric for Success
whenever I see those Sigma male memes or
whatever I really hope people are being
ironic uh but there was actually a
philosopher that brought up an idealized
version of man that that's right
Frederick n he did a couple more things
than just growing a cool mustache who
would have thought he came up with the
idealized human the Uber mench reading
from thus sarra man is a rope fastened
between animal and Superman or Uber MCH
a rope over an abbis A Dangerous going
across a dangerous wayf firing a
dangerous looking back a dangerous
shuddering and staying still what is
great in man is that he is a bridge and
not a goal what can be loved in man is
that he is a going across and and a
downgoing this idea of the Uber Man or
Superman was the idea of what a human
can be although not easily achievable he
put a lot of emphasis on the individual
we all have different circumstances we
all have different experience and
choices but we all have the capability
of overcoming ourselves no pain no gain
that does fit on a gym
t-shirt we shouldn't be content living a
comfortable life we should climb and
reach for the mountain tops to overcome
our limitations it's a difficult climb
but that's up there were the true beauty
lies a lot of nich's writing is very
poetic but often people tell me that or
even look at what I have as some
idealized version of oh he he can just
retire and live off his money and uh be
comfortable and that's great I'm not
trying to undervalue that I have that
but it's through the struggle that we
have the capacity to overcome ourselves
struggle isn't necessarily a bad thing
and I think personally to see life
through that lens of nche is so much
more appealing than previously mentioned
like Buddhism cuz we all going to have
tough circumstances instead of looking
at oh wo is me this is so difficult
rather saying yes embracing challenges
say yes to life life can be whatever you
want it's the ultimate video game create
your own values so yeah that is the
essence of becoming a uber mench
although very
oversimplified you know we're all in a
journey so let's keep dreaming let's
keep realizing our potential keep
questioning yourself keep striving
keep growing and who knows maybe you're
closer to an Uber bench than you thought
was that motivational I sure hope so I
want you guys to do well I genuinely
do I hope that helped see you guys in
the next video
bye everyone just clicks away for the ad
portion B distract them with your
acuteness it's working we all click
click clim on the internet sometimes you
click too much boom you got hacked
Bing Bong you should have used nordvpn
more than VPN everyone knows nordvpn
greatest VPN if you have any other VPN
then you're a dummy dunk maybe there's
an ad that pops up and you click on
which then gives you a malware nordvpn
protects you from this it's got malware
protection ransomware protection DS
protection protect you from fishing
attacks man in the- Middle attacks okay
good I need help you're
okay mommy's back now I can scream
protect you from Scream attacks no way
why live with a constant fear and stress
that something might happen to you that
compromise your security online just
download nordvpn couple bucks a month
you're good to go baby and it's a
VPN obviously I've been using n VPN for
years now and I can say it's fast it's
smooth it connects in just a couple
seconds and it's always running you
wouldn't even notice it keep it on on
your phone of course as well whenever
you connect to public Wi-Fi out in the
public or anything like that it works
amazing it's just a nice way to keep a
peace of mind and also it's a
VPN so you can watch things from
anywhere around the world you knew that
but you would know that double if you
download it and click on the link in the
description right now with my deal you
get the best deal of
nordvpn that is out every purchase of a
2-year plan
will get you a huge discount plus 4
months for free and if you're one of
those I keep hearing about different
it's risk-free try it for 30 days money
back guarantee what do you got to lose
check out the link in the description I
highly recommend it if you haven't
already unlock the full potential of the
internet saf L security when you with
nordvpn.com PewDiePie